The joe rogan experience.
So 2003 were in Brazil,
giant match.
Um,
Eddie beats could start with Dante says,
who was a very high level Jujitsu black belt and a,
he taps him,
he gets his back.
So I saw that you're pumped up,
you know,
you,
you felt very confident,
you felt good and you were,
you know,
you were zoned in,
but the idea that you were going to fight heuler Gracie seemed so crazy to me.
It,
this deep knowing what I know about the,
he's knowing what I know about the history of the family,
knowing what a legendary family there to see you.
My best friend standing there with Hoya,
Gracie and you guys are about to grapple.
I'm like,
and we're in Brazil like to this fucking trip.
I was starstruck.
I was like on some watching some three d TV or something.
It feels like you're right there on the mat.
And uh,
Eddie wound up catching him in a triangle.
It was the craziest fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
And,
uh,
it was like time stopped and he's like,
when you slapped that triangle on them,
it seemed like time stopped.
It didn't even seem real and you kept,
you kept jailbreaking man,
which is why it was hilarious.
That dexterity that you have with your legs and you're setting up this alma plot
to here
and um,
you got him in like full full rubber guard here.
Yeah.
That mission control is at the beginning of the rubber guard,
right?
Yeah.
You,
what you had then was the ability to control people.
You just didn't have as many variations on technique to attack with,
but you had this unbelievable fucking flexibility that a lot of people aren't
aware of.
You got some weird flexibility and not just flexibility but dexterity like in
places that maybe some people can grab their leg and put it,
you could put your leg there on its own,
but there's so many guys that are out there that w it's not that weird of
flexibility.
It's just getting into load is like if you got into yoga and you've got obsessed
with it,
eventually two years,
three years,
five years,
you'd have to be able to get into the very basic lotus position.
Yes.
There's a little more than that fell.
Are you being nice?
You know,
it's what it is.
I know what you're saying,
but the reality is you got some crazy legs,
something weird about your legs.
Your legs are like arms.
They move in strange ways,
right?
Hairs.
If he didn't try to pass right there and if we had just stayed in my guard,
I wouldn't have gotten them this one and a half and this transition.
Oh
yeah.
He got aggressive and he shouldn't have got aggressive.
He,
if he would've just been conservative,
I wouldn't have been able to go right here.
Right into the triangle,
boom over hook.
Oh,
John Jack right there.
That's all Jay.
You control that wrist and slapped it over.
And now this right here where you had the triangle locked in once here,
like right there,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Because before it was like one of those things where you're not breathing
because it's not totally locked in,
but once you had it locked behind the knee,
I was looking at,
I was like,
how is this guy going to survive and he's tapping.
he can't survive like no one can.
It's a human being.
When you have a guy your size and you slap a triangle on this tight.
See right here.
I wasn't sure Pam there.
I knew like when once he dropped down I was like,
holy shit that's locked in.
You were screaming,
oh my God.
And we were the only one screaming because everybody else was freaking out.
This Brazilian TV station,
it's set up cameras there.
They shut down the other matches so they could better light this match because
Hoya Gray,
she's a hero and they,
they were going to show boiler Gracie dominating the first time Abu Dhabi came
to Sao Paulo.
When you slap this triangle on them,
dude,
all you heard was me and Jamie Walsh.
Me and Jamie Walsh are yelling out,
pull the head,
pull the head.
Oh my God.
It was just madness.
Like,
Oh shit,
what?
We couldn't even believe it.
And then once you did pull the head and once he did tap,
it was like the world froze.
It was weird.
It was like a,
it didn't make sense.
The world just became some new place.
The world is a totally new element opened up.
Like the world became a new place.
Now all of a sudden Eddie Bravo is a champion martial artist.
Well I didn't win the championship.
It doesn't matter.
You just tap toilet Gracie like you're,
you're capable of tapping oil and grease.
That's championship level shit.
He tapped one of the greatest guys of all time.
It was,
it was a whole new world opened up.
It was just all of a sudden it was like,
Whoa,
this is weird.
It was weird.
It was weird to watch too,
man.
Cause I'm,
when I met you,
you're a purple belt.
You know,
you were really good prep belt,
weird,
crazy moves and shit.
And then um,
all of a sudden you're a brown belt and you were brown belt and Abu Dhabi,
Bro.
That's crazy.
You tap them when you were a brown belt.
So 11 long years go by and this Saturday night they had a rematch.
Um,
Eddie and boiler had a rematch and metamorris and that's what we were talking to
Hallett Gracie about on the phone.
They're promoting these professional Jiu Jitsu matches and uh,
it's awesome.
Uh,
Keenan Cornelius,
a fod,
um,
uh,
Kevin Casey,
Kevin Casey took Yuppie.
I'll just describe the whole event.
Um,
a lot of really,
really high level fighters.
Fought a lot of really good a Jujitsu fighters fought and the main event was
Eddie versus Hoya,
Gracie and,
uh,
11 years running.
I mean,
it's a long time in between matches and there was so much talk,
so much,
so many haters,
so many believers,
so many.
I mean,
there's so much back and forth between,
you know,
the people that thought that Eddie winning the first time was a fluke and the
people that legitimately thought that Eddie has a brilliant mind and a creative
mind for Jujitsu,
that's really unique.
And he can come up with a lot of techniques and his deck,
like he's talking,
he doesn't want to admit he's got weird dexterity in his legs,
but he can move his legs in weird ways.
He can wrap you up and triangles and stuff and,
and weird ways without a lot of people have to grab their foot and place in
places.
Um,
so he has these techniques that he's developed and like really created a bunch
of paths like been,
and a lot of Jujitsu guys do this,
this is not unique.
Um,
but his past where uniquely his and that he came up with a lot of different
techniques and approaches and refined a lot of other approaches that,
so he sort of adopted or adapted to Jujitsu.
And um,
the system in 2003 was really,
I'm not even a 10th of what it is now.
Um,
after 2003,
Eddie started teaching and then it became crazy.
Then the system started growing and new techniques were added and that there
became guys like to any provost who's a,
a a world champion as a brown belt guys came out of there that we're showing
that your,
your techniques weren't just for you and your crazy dexterity but you had broken
down things in a way that you know,
uh,
other people hadn't done before and a weird way your,
your,
your positions,
your very unique.
And um,
there was a lot of people that do want to accept that for whatever reason.
And there was all this,
oh,
he got lucky,
all fluke,
all this.
So Saturday night rolls around and I couldn't imagine there being more
anticipation in a room before something.
And it was a cool anticipation too because one of the things I like about
Jujitsu is no one's going to get knocked the fuck out.
Even if you get choked out,
you know,
there's something about like seeing a friend fight.
It gets real rough.
I mean we've been friends with MMA fighters,
but I've never been as friendly with an MMA fighters.
I am with you,
you know I've,
but no one,
a guy and liking a guy and then watched him get head kicked.
It's hard to do,
you know,
so it didn't have the date that,
that aspect to it,
but it was all positive is what I'm trying to say.
It was all just holy shit,
it's going down.
Um,
and once it did,
there was no points because it's a 20 minute match.
So for 20 minutes it's either submission or no points,
but in that 20 minutes you swept him on multiple occasions.
You've got side control.
He never threatened you in any way,
shape or form.
You swept in with electric chairs.
You threatened him with a neck crank and you threatened him with this nasty
fucking submission move on his knee.
Which I don't,
you know,
I don't know how he didn't tap cause that was hard to watch,
man,
when we were sitting there watching.
That was the move.
I got you on the high time.
Yes.
That movie's so painful.
Just that photo shoot,
that shit hurt,
man.
It hurts.
And somehow or another,
a heuler just mean,
look,
he's a warrior.
He just,
he didn't want to tap.
He just decided he wasn't going to tap.
Um,
for people who,
um,
have never seen Jujitsu before,
that was like the perfect introduction match because it was so exciting.
There was so much madness and there was a bunch of times where you were,
uh,
you were working on shit and he rolled you over onto your back and then he swept
him again.
So there's all these like seesaws when he would roll,
you'd be on your back.
Oh,
she has back.
But you on your back is different than a lot of people on your back because
that's how he tapped him in the first fight.
You tapped him from your back.
Your back is,
you know,
your,
your card is crafty.
So it was,
it was an incredibly thrilling match because there was constant threat at all
times.
And even from him,
man,
he's still oily.
Gracie,
you always knew.
I mean,
he's still that champion.
If something went wrong,
if you didn't dot your i's and cross your t's,
Ellis,
not sure I was going to win this fight.
How could you be sure he's fucking crazy.
I mean,
he's soiler fucking Gracie.
I never said that.
I'm going to go out there and just strangle them.
I was just,
I didn't know.
I hadn't competed in so long.
Look right here,
I'm faking like I'm going to wrestle
because I didn't think he was just going to let me pull them into quarter guard.
I thought at this point my wow.
He just thought he was just going to try some totally different ship,
but this is what he always does.
Every morning before I work out,
I warm up on the stair master.
I go to youtube,
but Heuler ADCC pick one of his matches and that's how I get,
that gives me all the motivation.
I just watch him roll and he's so good at this,
but I thought he would try to pass to the other side and I thought this
position,
I thought this position was going to be the hardest to get and this was the key.
If I could just get quarter guard in this position,
I felt like I could get them
and was a bunch of crazy rules.
In this match as well.
One of the rules was that boiler was wearing like these skin tight shorts.
Eddie was wearing Gucci Pants.
Um,
and Heuler was allowed to grab Eddie's ski pants but Eddie wasn't allowed to
grab toilet shorts.
So it was weird to watch man.
Cause there's times where he's like giving you a Wedgie and pulling on your
pants.
Yeah.
He's pulling them down and could see my underwear.
And when
and when he got to that a leg lock and he's trying to defend that leg lock and
you're tearing his knee apart and he's hanging onto your,
your cough.
It's saved him.
The pat saved him.
Yeah.
Cause he didn't have the pants.
I would have stomped on that foot and got the extra power because he,
oh,
I mean a man,
his,
I think his knee popped at least seven times.
We were talking.
I'm like,
we could stop this now.
You sure?
He goes,
no,
I'm fine.
And I'm popping.
I'm like,
what about that?
Cause I'm fine.
I'm like,
it just kept popping on my damn.
Well you sure cause everything's good.
I said,
everything's fine.
Like we're talking throughout this whole match,
like right here.
He wanted the under up really,
really bad.
So I was saying it's hard to get this time.
Huh?
Cause the first time he got the under under,
I'm a lot of work cause that's a hard one.
It's only because I would rather go against a guy who wasn't really mad at me.
If I could joke with you and get like a,
like this is just for fun.
Right,
right.
Then I feel like,
okay,
I can get this guy now because I could win because he's not mad.
He's mad.
Oh Shit.
Like I would never want to find like a Diego Sanchez type guy was mad at me.
I'm like,
oh no,
no,
no.
I want to find a guy that's like friendly and shit.
Hilarious.
We were,
I was just constantly joking with them constantly.
And uh,
during like after I swept and when I get on top and the electric turn them,
hold him,
I go,
you can't move from here.
So just hang on and relax.
I need about a minute to rust and I go,
you can't do nothing.
Just relax.
Because there are some positions where there,
I don't know,
maybe three or four positions are like cradles there,
like rustling cradles.
And it happens here where the guy on the bottom just can't do anything.
He's not getting tapped but he can't move.
He's to completely wrapped up and I used those spots to rest.
So,
uh,
but it's hilarious that you told,
oh,
just relax.
When me and John,
Jack Russel,
we are always talking smack to each other.
Me and John.
John always goof and we're,
oh,
it's always a joke.
It's always,
always me and Sean.
It's like a thing we do and I do it.
There's certain guys that I roll with that I do that too.
I don't like to do it too much to my students because then it seems like,
um,
acting all arrogant against a guy that I,
he's one of my students,
he's a blue belt or a white belt.
Right.
I'm not,
that would look really douchey but playful.
But because John Jack can smash me anytime he wants.
I talk like I pretend like I'm arrogant cause it's funny because he didn't do
anything you want.
So no matter how Douchey I get,
we know it's just doesn't make any sense cause he's killing me.
But um,
uh,
so same thing here.
I have so much respect for him that,
that I feel like I could just joke around with them and I don't want him to be
mad at me.
Well that's good.
That's a good attitude to have man.
Especially after 11 years between the matches.
Um,
it's cool that you,
uh,
you kept that feeling and you were completely destroyed,
completely respectful,
rather uh,
the entire way up to the promotion of it.
Your,
your opinion of him,
you know,
you were,
you were like praising what a legend he is and you were very self deprecating
about your first victory to um,
this was a 20 minute match and because there was no submission,
uh,
it's a draw.
Metamorris is doing a unique thing and they,
I don't know if they've got the rules totally ironed out where they want him to
yet,
but what the,
what they're trying to do is discourage people from point fighting.
And what that means is work towards submission at all times.
And you may get a submission and you may not get a submission,
but the,
the idea is you're,
you're seeing real Jujitsu here and they've accomplished that.
Like everyone was going for submissions,
whether it was Guy Mendez or half a Mendez or you know,
Kenan Cornelia's,
everyone was going for submissions.
Um,
sometimes they didn't get them,
but it was really exciting because of that because guys couldn't just sort of
wrestle to a certain position and then hold.
Um,
but if this was a scored match,
you would have beat them handily.
I mean,
you swept him times,
you get side
control on them and you had two near submissions.
This is where he gets the under the crowd goes nuts because he has been fighting
for the under hook for five minutes and he finally gets it.
And this is the position that we're in and our first match.
So all the grades,
there's like,
yes,
he got the undercut so technical that he finally got it.
And I still have them in quarter guard here.
So I was a little worried,
but you see what I'm doing with my right hand.
I'm going under the knee right here.
I never really do that and I was keeping him from going,
no hand pass.
So I'm like,
oh okay cool.
This is nice.
He can't go no ham pass cause I'm holding his leg out and like that.
And I've never really done that before.
This is the first time,
it's crazy.
You see how I got my left hand?
She can't go.
No hand pass.
I'm holding open his legs.
So I felt comfortable even though I didn't have the under hook,
I just had to somehow get a lockdown.
So for my people,
they know,
they see me fighting like this.
All this is every day in the gym.
This is how it looks.
I start in this position,
this is how it looks.
So to the Gracie side,
they probably thought he was a winning right here,
right?
My mom was freaking out.
My mom thought he was killing me.
This at this moment.
You got the lockdown somewhere in here you got the lockdown and when you got the
lockdown here,
the crowd went fucking crazy.
That was crazy.
I get the lock down.
My guys go nuts.
He gets the under hook.
His crowd goes nuts.
I get the lock down.
My crowd goes nuts that it was so crazy.
The lockdowns way bigger though.
The the what?
What?
For folks who don't know the lockdown,
when you got a guy who's really good at it and he has you in half guard and
slaps it on your legs in jeopardy,
you might tear your fucking knee.
You're getting manipulated.
You've got two legs against one,
and when a guy's really good at it,
a guy like Eddie,
when they're really good at it and they have two legs against one,
it puts you in a precarious position and it's,
it makes you vulnerable to a lot of different sweeps and here you're flipping a
coin.
Of course,
that's when the crowd went nuts.
We'll dude,
you're,
you've got his leg in a mangled position here.
There's electric chair right here.
I didn't think this was the plan.
The plan was exactly what happened.
That was the plan.
I was going to go,
just do what I do at the gym every night.
This is exactly what I do every night.
This is nothing new.
It wasn't a special strategy for boiler.
So that was John jocks.
Whole plan is to get me to do what I normally do.
The Best Shit.
I'm at a dude out there on him and then he reversed you for a second.
I didn't have the leg on my shoulders,
so I go let us go back and through them and get it.
So it looked like he swept me.
But I went back to put that leg back on my shoulder and I went rock right back
up.
I do it all the time,
you know?
So now I'm in a position,
this is where you rocked it with momentum cause you had full control over that
leg.
It just wasn't on my shoulder.
I had to go back and scoop it up.
So now I'm on top and now I'm on a,
I'm in the electric chair on top and this is where I'm talking to him.
I'm like,
you can't do anything here.
Just relax.
This is where I rest.
I went through a lot of explosion and I right here I have control of this and
that's why he was doing that thing with his hands because people would want it.
Like why is he throwing his hands up in the air?
Like you know,
like he did that a couple of times when you got him into side control.
He did that and then I pass the guard pool in right here.
I'm,
I'm still,
he's still stuck.
I got him in a cradle.
But that makes sense now because everybody wondered why he was doing that with
his hands.
People are like,
oh,
heuler was complaining.
No,
he's complaining because you were talking shit to him.
You're saying you're stuck here.
Don't,
don't move.
He was saying,
I can't do nothing.
He's holding me like,
this is Jujitsu.
We're holding,
we're square,
we're clenching and squeezing.
Right.
You know,
and he's all like,
how could he complain about that?
He's totally a mobile here.
Even though I pass,
I pass,
I let go the lockdown and passed his guard.
The reason why the past was guaranteed is because of the control I have on his
leg.
I have a head and arm and the leg.
So that pass was easy.
As soon as I let go,
the lockdown didn't want to let it go until I rest a little bit.
And then finally I let go the leg last and now I'm in side control.
And here's the big transition.
I thought he was going to turn into me,
but he turns away.
So I'm like,
Ooh,
that's even easier.
But he's rolling in a nice way,
but I had to turn it into 100% here.
So this is halfway.
This is a neck crank that I do to get the guy to give me his back.
So I'm net cranking them here and if he pulls his left arm all the way out,
um,
I usually transition to the back and that's what he did right there.
So now I'm getting up and his left arms free now.
So all I gotta do is get up on my right knee and then swirled in the back.
That's what I'm going to do here.
I wanted the twister.
That was the plan.
The plan was to get them in a twister,
but he did a really good job of just shrugging me off.
So now I gotta start over again.
So at this point I'm thinking this is what I'm really thinking.
Um,
I thought the most important thing is for me is to go out there and not get
smoked and not get tapped in 20 seconds or 30 seconds.
Cause that would be,
that would crush me.
I would be the worst possible thing.
So let's make sure that doesn't happen.
And if I lose,
if I tap,
at least let me go out there and give,
we have 20 minutes.
Let's see some good 10 plan,
a technique from my people just to show that it works if he taps it.
So at this point I'm thinking I did so much to them,
right.
That textbook 10 planet shit all the way through.
Note for note that I thought if the worst case scenario,
if he taps me on one second,
at least I got some good shit in my mind,
in my mind,
cause that's how much respect I have for right.
I'm like,
she could still get me,
I'm not over.
We got 13 minutes.
So in my mind I already won.
I go,
I won.
So when you think that way and you're,
I thought I already did all this shit.
So the worst case scenario,
he tasks.
Now I did a good job.
So for some reason that made me just want to attack a more and go,
let's just keep putting this,
just keep piling it up.
Oh here's another one,
Dan,
and see if I could do another one.
Oh here's another one.
And the,
I just change.
Should I go?
Damn,
I'm not going to go for a twister.
I'm going to go for a vaporizer.
So when I,
when I get them in an electric chair,
he doesn't tap.
When I test this flexibility,
if they don't tap,
I can just sweep them and get on top and set them up for a twister.
Which I already tried,
but I made the decision.
I go,
you know what?
There's a lot.
He's pretty good at shaking me off the back.
If I just go to the vaporizer,
it'll logistics schools,
the twister,
and I do it all the time and that's good enough.
So that was the plan.
I go,
he's not stopping the electric chair,
so I'm a go back and get another another.
I thought about rubber guard for a second,
third,
and I thought,
you know what?
You see how he got the under hood?
You see that I went,
rubber guard locked down,
whipped him.
He had the under hook,
but that whip boom,
I sucked and wham Bam.
That's a little whipped down Combo,
a very important combo to master.
And now I got the under it.
So I thought he's not stopping the electric car tonight because if he would have
been able to,
he can I,
I'm able to do electric chairs easy.
So I knew I could just go back and more money in the bank.
I knew he couldn't stop it.
He just was perplexed here.
So I go,
you know what,
I'm,
I got to go to the vaporizer.
I that,
which means I got to get his leg over to my left shoulder on the other side.
I need to get my head.
I want me,
I just need to squash his leg down and get on top in a,
uh,
leg drag type position,
but a leg drag with a lockdown to maintain control.
So right now I'd go back to the electric chair for the third or fourth time,
and I was really confident at this point.
I just knew he wasn't going to tap from the electric chair and I didn't want to
pass this guard to get on top and try the twister.
I already made the decision.
So for folks who don't know what we're talking about here,
the electric chair is a move where you've got a guy literally in a full split
and you're controlling his bottom leg and the other leg,
you're,
you're forcing it up towards his head.
Most people don't have the flexibility to tolerate it and a lot of times they
tap just from that.
You're like literally ripping their crotch
part.
Yeah.
And and right here,
you know what I didn't get,
I didn't get the position I wanted,
so I'm letting him get on top so I can set it up again.
I go,
he cannot stop it.
He can't stop my under hugs.
I already knew I had him beat on the inside.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to set it up again and go back to the cause.
I wanted the vaporizer.
He foiled to vaporize.
I lost control of his leg,
so I got to start over again.
So all of these times where he's on top,
where the artists I called the tide has shifted back and forth.
This was just you resetting
did he could not stop my half guard game.
I've just,
the confidence just kept growing and growing.
So even though he has the under a,
I go watch,
I'm going to get the under hook back.
I was already getting it back.
There's no way you could stop it.
Right?
I see that boom whip down.
I go,
I'm just going to keep doing it.
He can't stop it.
So,
and then I'm going to start all over.
I know he's not going to be able to,
he's not going to shake the lockdown.
The lockdown is too strong.
He was never close to ever getting his leg out.
I was so confident at this point I was getting a little gas and um,
I knew I could recover.
All I need is like a little time.
So,
um,
to,
to uh,
hide the gaseous or the gas in is the fact that he hasn't stopped breathing.
I'm dying inside,
but I would stop breathing.
You know,
like when Jason Walks into your house and you're in the closet and you're like,
but then you go,
yeah,
I was doing that just so he wouldn't smell.
Now I did it again.
I knew I could do it again.
Now I've got to get his leg to the other side.
I don't look at it at sea.
I'm holding onto his leg.
I needed to get it to the other side of my body.
Right?
So I'm like,
you know what?
Damn,
I lost it again.
Let me,
let me do it again.
So look at that.
He'll be doing it again.
They thought he reversed me.
But I go,
I'm just setting it up now.
I've got the leg over right there.
Boom.
That's where I want to be.
That's the transition right there.
And I go,
well,
I'm going to go after it.
Like I thought about it for a second there,
but I go,
no,
you know what?
I'm going to roll.
I can't just reach back for it.
I got to have set it up.
I'm going to set it up right here.
Squash them down.
I thought about it again,
but then he stopped it right there and I go,
okay,
let me set it up differently.
But then we got broke up here and this is where all the controversial,
what the hell was going on here.
I knew what position we were in top stoner control,
right.
I knew the position.
I'm there all the time.
He had no idea what I was doing.
So,
and he didn't know that.
I knew.
He thought it was just some crazy,
weird position.
And uh,
he didn't know where he was.
And,
uh,
I was,
I would say I pulled guard right here and I was going to say here like gimme
your leg,
let me throw it over.
I'm going to get on top and we're going to go back and I show you exactly the
whole thing.
I was going to show it.
I was going to do it from the top.
See,
I'm trying to do it from step one and then I was going to take them over and I
was showing him the sweep instead of just getting in the position.
He's all confused.
He don't know what's going on.
I'm trying to,
I go,
you got to get your leg over it.
He's not,
he keeps refusing.
I'm like,
man,
he's not letting me get in the position and look.
He's like,
no,
no.
And he didn't know.
In his defense he didn't know the position,
but I know exactly what's going on.
He refuses to get in the position and then I'm just thinking I need a rest a
little bit.
Anyways,
so this is bullshit.
I'm not going to argue with we.
We're just arguing here.
He won't let me.
I know exactly that.
Then I decided at fuck that.
Fuck this shit.
I'm not going to get fucked here.
And the crowd was going nuts.
So young,
replay,
replay and show Scott Nelson looks over right here.
He looks over to Hallock and he goes,
what do you want to do?
Halleck Hallux said stand them up,
start standing.
And when,
look,
he's going to walk over right now.
And I said,
what did he say?
And then they put the replay on,
he goes,
Hal except stand him up.
He said,
stand them up.
And I'm like,
fuck that.
We're not standing up.
And then the replay comes on and everybody looks at the replay and then heuler
just gets down and gets into position.
I go,
look,
I know a position is going on so he let me have it.
See he said,
okay.
No,
no resistance.
Once the video came out,
they was trying to sneak that left knee in.
Yeah.
And this is top store control right there.
Right there.
Stone of control from the back.
And there's,
you don't have to tough,
he didn't have your risks before.
They didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
None of it.
What I want here is I want him to push me away because I'm going to dip and
roll.
I'm going to Tuck and roll,
but it he holds onto me.
I can't tuck and roll and the whole time so I got to make it look like I want to
smash them and squeeze them cause I could pass it anytime.
The past is guaranteed.
Do you want the for sure pass or do you want to try to Tuck and roll and go for
the kill right away and go after the vaporizer and I thought I'm going right for
the vaporizer.
Fuck passing his guard and then he recovers half guard and all that shit.
I wanted to go for the kill right here.
So right now I'm on my side.
I'm setting it up.
I need to be up on my knees but just only do is need to get up.
See I'm getting up.
All they gotta do is really get on top,
but I know I could get on top of them anytime I want.
I know this position.
I'm just waiting.
Now I'm on my knees.
I collected some gas,
I recovered.
He can't get out.
I'm in control here.
His legs are all mangled.
So what I want to do is turn to my right and roll on my left shoulder.
But at what a resting,
all I'm doing is rusting.
I'm going to turn to my right roll on my left shoulder,
but I need him to push me.
So I say I'm cool.
I'm selling the fact that I want to squeeze him and I want to see him to see,
and I was pushing away.
He bought it,
he bought the fact that I want us to please.
So this is what I always do.
So now I'm gurgling going like I hate this.
Like I hate this,
but look,
he's going to help me see how we helped me.
And he pushed me through.
He pushed me through this,
done.
Now you got this and I thought for sure he was going to tab.
This is the vaporizer.
No one has ever not tapped to this.
This is in my arsenal,
the nastiest leg lock.
This is a,
it's a calf crank and it's a toe hold at the same time and he can't protect
himself with his other leg is other leggings were on his other leg so his other
leg is useless.
I can use both my arms as opposed to the calf crank from the truck.
The calf came from the truck.
You can't use both arms for fear of getting arm barred with one of them who
left,
so you need to protect that other leg.
Anyway,
he's got a free leg to break shit apart,
but in from the vaporizer he can't protect with his other leg.
It's out of the mix and you could use both arms because there's no arm bar and
it's a,
it's a leg compression and a told in one,
it's the nastiest leg lock in my arsenal and the fact that his leg popped at
least seven times,
it was popping and cracking and I'm telling them right here,
I would say,
I'm asking him,
I go,
dude,
we can end this.
And he's like,
no,
see that.
He's like,
no,
we can stop this.
It keeps popping.
He goes,
that's normal.
That's normal.
I go with it keeps popping.
And uh,
he refused the tap.
He refused man.
And I was yanking.
So I thought I'm going to,
I was doing things I never did to that they Bryson,
I usually just grab the toes with both ends,
twist it in pool and it's really easy.
And the calf crank from the truck.
Another thing that you need,
you need to stomp your left,
the inside of your left foot with your right foot.
You got to shove your leg deeper into the how nasty that looks.
But in the CAF crank,
you need to stop in this one.
You don't need to stomp.
You could just keep your legs,
figure forward both arms.
That's enough pressure.
Just leave your legs.
Figure four.
But if for some crazy reason they don't tap like he did,
then you would go to the stomp to add even more pressure.
But he was holding the Geek Pat so I could see he's holding my right leg.
I need to use my right foot and stomp on the inside of my left foot.
I need to pull it up and stomp on it and I can get his hands free.
I can't get my leg free.
You see I was holding it but I mean is so I decided,
you know what,
I'm just,
I generally don't need to stomp on that foot,
so I'm still trying to make him tap like everyone else taps without it,
but see how he's holding it.
So I grabbed his foot,
I'm twisting it and I thought there's like a minute left.
I go,
I'm want to give it everything.
I got one more time and I just grabbed his foot,
something I never do when I twisted it and shoved it,
like trying to shove it like in his ribs man.
And he still wouldn't tap and near the popping and it just,
he didn't care.
He just kept going.
He knew that if he didn't tab it would be a draw and that's what he needed.
He couldn't have you tap twice.
He tap him twice.
He has nothing.
The fact that he's holding onto my g pants there,
that's what's saving him.
You know he crazy.
Yeah.
He's getting serious danger right here.
If you had to do it again,
would you do it with the pants again?
Yes.
Because the key pad made those electric chairs so easy.
He could,
he was never close to pulling his leg out of lockdown.
So the traction is just unbelievable.
I mean,
the pants,
the pants were bad for him and a lot of ways,
but it saved them right here in this one position.
Yeah,
it did save him,
but I would,
yeah,
I would,
uh,
I would have went back to pants anyways,
that whole pants scandal thing,
um,
I'm using my hands to wear pants.
They said,
okay,
you go wear pants if you promise not to change your mind.
I want her to change my mind.
They said,
you promise not to change it.
And then so they made me wear what I asked for.
So,
um,
I met his lawyer,
his lawyer.
It ended up being really,
really cool,
man.
The guy that was,
uh,
trying to protect a heuler from the pant.
That's when you're twisting it do.
Yeah.
I'm pushing down and try to smash.
He's obviously in some serious pain here,
but it's incredible.
He's not tapping.
What do you think happened to the knee?
If you had to guess?
Is this some damage?
Maybe.
Maybe he isn't.
He always pops and that's the thing I'll say about him is that he won't tap to
joint locks.
Like you remember when a Sakharova got him in that Kamora yeah.
And,
uh,
they stopped the fight and he's like,
don't stop the fight.
I,
I'm there all day.
I'm fine.
Like,
I don't get tapped from those things.
Yeah.
Um,
so like how it said,
please don't watch this on youtube.
If you do watch on Youtube,
please support metamorris just go there.
And I purchased one for 20 bucks.
There's a lot of high level matches,
um,
and,
uh,
people,
it's really fun.
Okay.